when it comes to dance
you're the visual representation
of that sound or that beat you're not
needing to communicate with your words
[Music]
you can just move in that feeling
music
something's telling me right now
potentially
we did a live show made us want to make
a third movie this is a place where we
can really redesign what Magic Mike
actually is my grandch
arge this is the third Magic Mike
there's a real solid love story of an
older woman and a younger man hey what's
not to love
[Music]
what the dancing was going to be Luke
and Allison are the most important
people on this entire movie
is my name and the choreographers my
name is Luke Broderick and I am one of
the choreographers honestly it's just
such a big deal for all of us
it's really exciting to be a
choreographer on a film like this
because dance is one of the key
components in the storytelling
this movie really explores dancing as a
way of expression and in a way almost as
an exorcism of oneself
[Music]
the expectations are hard because we're
on a third movie if you get an
opportunity to do something again you
always have to go bigger you know it's
always go big or go home naturally this
one's called Last Dance for a reason so
you know we're going to send it off on a
big bang
all right here we go and Playback
[Applause]
let's say that if we're gonna do a third
one I want to bring the guys that we've
found on the live show and I want to put
them in the movie
man you guys are still tossing them that
way think about tossing them up we
didn't have to actually translate too
much from these shows to the movie
because everyone is high-end performers
it's very impressive they're technically
perfect and their dedication and how
good they are and the joy you feel the
passion in every move
picking which ones that was the hard
part because we have so many dancers on
so many different shows and didn't get
to be in the movie
the guys that we initially have
auditioned felt confident in themselves
that they were able to do it but we were
able to see something in them that we
were like you got it you got something
we wanted to see who these guys are
their personalities how they style
themselves that's kind of what helps
make Magic Mike it's the person behind
the dancer I've been scouting myself and
come take a look at what I found
Sebastian is an extraordinary dancer
Chan from the first time he saw him he's
like he should be an actor he works so
hard and cares about dancing so much
he'll watch something he's like I'm like
listen listen buddy it was pretty good
yeah like your toe doing this and this
is not gonna break it give it up
everybody for Mr J D
I'm
not a long time he does 10 shows a week
in Las Vegas and he does between six to
ten like giant flips per show no one
else does it in the show he's just
extraordinary Gonzalez he's from Puerto
Rico he brings like a certain flavor
that you only have if you're from that
part of the world office auditioned you
just couldn't pass up how good he was
the guys that I've gotten to know each
and every single one of them can do
something that no one else can do on the
planet
[Music]
's a great dancer but he does stuff
physically that not a lot of
professional dancers could pull off
chatting I know we've seen him dance but
I think he's gonna blow people's minds
especially with this final dance with
Chan there is no actual music it's just
them dancing we gave our utter bodies
and souls into learning this thing
beginning of
is Mike writing is wrong he had
he had a visual representation of what
would have happened if I would have
stopped her and told her no the working
of it out we just kind of call it like
it's a chancy dance there is no exact
science in water
how much water is down is there is there
a lot of water and a lot of water
actually makes you be able to grip more
if it's just a little bit of water it's
going to be more slippy and it's like we
had to learn this over months and months
and months
Kylie Shea does a portion of Swan Lake
in there which was really special
because she's such an incredible ballet
dancer I had chills I almost wanted to
cry and I was really surprised of how it
impacted me to feel the dance so close
you know on the same floor like on my
feet and everything
you see Salmo going through you see the
story of where it happened and they
didn't have to say anything and we
didn't have to say anything we just had
to make the movement and see them
execute it and that was the result
so
we love the sexiness but we also love a
little bit of romance and this movie has
a lot of romance it's an honor to be a
choreographer on a film like this and
then to have a collaborator like Chan we
were able to take it to another level
you get to meet so many people that are
so good at their job that you can just
back up that's beyond special
[Music]
thank you